hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner get and this is
gonna be a continuation of the last
video the deaf stream was pretty long so
I decided to cut this up in a couple
pieces this is gonna be the last video
of the Dead stream and this is going to
be about the weapons that the old cast
is going to be getting and specific the
armor is going to be one full set for
the wolven and the weapons are going to
be for the entire cast that also
includes the woman and remember the new
hero black prior is not included in any
of this so definitely keep that in mind
as always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being belts changes your updates patch
notes and leaks so you want to be kept
up today with everything that's
happening a foreigner just stays
subscribe to the channel and with that
let's get started so first up is the
pictures for the Wulin armor which is
shaolin noushad JJ inti Andy judges
outfits don't look too unique but I
still respect it nonetheless looks
really nice liusia had some white powder
or makeup on her face that is a standard
Chinese or Japanese thing I keep
forgetting what culture it is but it's
pretty standard I'm actually kind of
glad this is part of the armor evident
plain usha I would have definitely
grabbed this Shaolin looks like he aged
40 years and has and has had enough of
marching fire and now he's an old man so
that's a pretty nice look if you want to
have him more of an aged Shaolin you can
definitely grab that and tea on D has a
frost metallic armor it looks pretty
cool but I think as other armors are a
little bit better now that the armors
aughtta let's get to the weapons and for
the weapons we have a little bit of a
frost look for the winter theme although
I do believe it's a little bit too late
for that but it's pretty cool
nonetheless first set is our a Musha
berserker centurion and conquer next up
we have gladiator Highlander JJ and ken
say while bringer Nobu she knew she and
Orochi are next with peacekeeper Raider
shaman and Shaolin following next to
them the second last group is shinobi Xu
go key T on D and Valkyrie and then
ending off with the two behemoths warden
and warlord for the last of the weapons
these weapons are pretty nice they're
pretty good
personally they're not the greatest but
I still think they're pretty cool I do
enjoy the frost the type of look I might
have to put that on my gladiator since I
do have a winter theme for one of the
characters hey guys let me know what you
guys think about these weapons in the
comments below sorry I couldn't fit into
the other video I thought the video was
too long and I wanted to split stuff up
so this is going to be the end of this
video like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe before
I cover the informational side of
foreigner that being balanced changes
here are updates patch notes and leaks
if you want to be kept in today with
everything in foreign or just they
subscribe to the channel I'll keep you
all to date my two most recent videos
would be on screen if you guys do want
to check that out when that guy said Bev
gross today I think for watching the
video and peace out enjoy the rest of
your day
[Music]
you